they all gotta have a roof over their
head you got me there and uh for most
people a house is the biggest purchase
of your life that leads me to the point
of me basically setting the table with
millennials in gen z these 20 and
30-somethings out there
they want to buy a house but a lot of
them
are struggling let's get into the story
so it's called the millennial housing
crisis student debt is wiping
out home ownership dreams let's pull
that story up dave all right so crazy
stat alert for the people listening at
home right now
um
by the way
before we get into the story here's what
i'd like if you currently
have a mortgage
or own a home
throw a thumbs up in there can we do
that or throw a house emoji yeah throw a
house emoji okay throw a house emoji if
you're currently renting
right throw a thumbs down in there
thumbs down emoji i mean that sounds
like it's bad it's not a bad thing but
for this segment okay uh yeah throw it
throw a thumb what do you want to throw
it down if you own a house thumbs down
if you rent that's fine but there's
nothing that's not i'm not saying
there's anything wrong with that nothing
wrong with that that's right seinfeld
reference all right another one so how
do manage these emojis here we go anyway
so millennial housing crisis student
debt is wiping out home ownership dreams
for millennials and even gen z so crazy
stat alert
60 of millennials are delaying the
purchase of a home because of their
student debt that is no small number six
and ten people three out of five people
are basically saying i can't even even
look to buy a house right now it's just
not in the cards which not necessarily a
bad thing right okay so this is the
story from the national association of
realtors we'll talk on that all business
insiders but those stats came from
the nar
so let's look at three issues
three reasons for this issue of why
millennials just can't afford houses or
not buying houses so number one you all
we all recall what happened in 2008 the
housing crisis and the housing basically
housing market has screwed millennials
over left and right so they suffered the
most from the last housing crisis
because basically in 2008 the average
millennial was somewhere between 21 and
27 let's say the older millennials they
were just getting out of college they
were looking to you know get jobs you
know maybe rent buy houses there was not
a time for them buy a house that wasn't
happening they entered a dismal job
market basically which lingered for
years right in the middle of the last
recession 2008 the great recession and
that which led to years of stagnant
wages people want to make that money but
they couldn't because jobs were
basically not um
there in 2008 2009 2010. so then you get
the lingering effects of this financial
crisis we got that which
meant it took a handful of years someone
started making that money right to build
wealth they just couldn't do it because
it was was tough so aka they couldn't
save up
for a down payment on a house
this is the problem here and all
all this going on
while they're struggling with student
debt bingo there it is yeah that's how
we're about to say yeah okay well done
so the burden of high student debt also
sees many americans making tough
financial choices between get this
priority list let's have fun with this
at home
priority by the way a lot of renters a
lot of renters what do we got uh we got
our friend zachary pasano saying yeah i
bought a house uh i just got a home in
austin 25 years old but i'm renting it
out to the homies cool what else oh yeah
what else we get out there jorge
cervantes thumbs down he's renting
michael lopez bought
uh alex renting lodiana uh renting lucas
renting lee renting a lot of people
renting guys do me a favor if you're
listening right now there's you know 50
60 people live right now i'm sure we'll
get up to 100 during the show if not
more
throw your age in there
21 25 30 40. i want to know how old you
guys are what renting or
clearly more people are renting right
now i'd like to get some agents
of majors
okay
as you see some stuff throw that in
there i'm gonna get on with the story
and then i wanna i wanna put this out
there so we talked about the student
loan debt right and it's making having
um millennials make some tough
financial decisions so the tough
financial decisions the the as this
story from business insider lays out for
us
is between buying a home
investing investing in retirement
getting married starting a family or
saving up for other purchases so what i
wanted to do was i said all right this
is these are our decisions
everyone's got these same decisions to
make
what's the correct order to do these
decisions in what's the correct order to
make these things happen by the way you
got some agents for me throw them out
there yeah david let's see okay
24 21 27 renting tom wolf 37 gerardo
munoz 29 devin higgins 26. okay um yeah
19 18 26 31 26 devin's 26 15 times yeah
kevin devin you're respected are you
twenty seconds we got that david and
we're wondering okay so listen everyone
has these decisions to make in my
opinion
here's the order in which you should be
doing these things right in my opinion
there's an order to how you should get
your financial life in order and here's
the here's the order because the
basically business insider's like you
should buy a house you start a family
should save for retirement number one
start to save that money
start to save that money understand
why saving is so important number two
then you can start invest investing in
retirement then
while you're doing this make sure you
have a career because at the point where
you're saving or starting to invest it
might just be a job might not be a job
that you'll be at forever but eventually
by age 30 i would definitely recommend
that you have a career a profession a
trade a skill not just going from job to
job to job to job i have friends that
are in their late 30s who are 40 who are
starting over in a new career and that
is
freaking
tough to do you meaning from 22 to 40
you didn't figure out your niche in this
life you didn't have a specialty you
don't have a skill it's tough i'm not
saying that that the life's over people
are living to 80 90 100 no problem you
get 50 years to figure it out yeah but
by 40 you need to be known for something
drake has a song
that just came out uh
uh
lemon lemon lemon chicken lemon butter
something like that
lemon something lemon pepper lemon lemon
pepper freestyle that's what it is if
anyone watches that and he goes
people are famous for i don't even know
what i have to have the time i got to
ask people what their profession is
okay yeah if people don't know what you
do yeah what are you doing people should
understand this is what this guy does oh
your friend john what does he do oh this
he's a special she's a lawyer does that
oh a friend kelly what does she do oh
she's an economist or okay oh danielle
she's this is what she does uh bill what
does he do
i think he's like a dj or i don't know
he might think he like works do you have
friends like that
what is he doing now what is he doing
yeah have a profession anyway once you
have that those boom boom boom you've
saved you've invested you have a
profession you've got like your personal
life in order i'm not talking about
other people i'm not talking about
finding your soulmate i'm not talking
about marriage kids once you get that in
order then you can look to the outside
world
right then you can get married then you
can start a family then
in my opinion is when you can buy a
house
americans have been fed by a house
american dream buy a house people are 21
buying houses it's like you don't
understand there's other things that you
should be doing before you lock yourself
into a mortgage or a home there's
nothing wrong with uh having a house but
there's a certain order you should do it
and i'll tell you why
you know you know who's done a really
good job of convincing people
that renting is throwing away money you
know who it is my parents your parents
okay a hundred percent because they've
been fed
a a uh propaganda
from the um the realtor association
right we talked about that the um
national association of realtors has
done an amazing job at convincing people
that renting is throwing away money yeah
they've done an amazing job at saying
why are you renting you could own a home
you can own a home
why are you ready what are you crazy
you're just throwing away money you're
pissing away money every month
ah they've done a great job at that but
are they right talk is money
all we talk is money if you enjoyed that
short clip from the sauce cast click
here to watch another click here to
watch the full episode or just stay
broken